Donald Trump is officially declaring war.
On Republicans, yes, on, I guess, what is still
considered his own Republican Party, Donald Trump
put out a statement yesterday going after many
Republicans, but in particular Mitch McConnell.
Take a listen to this. Donald Trump putting out a
statement through the Save America PAC, which is
a pro Trump PAC. Trump can't tweet now, so he's
putting it out through the PAC. Let's go through
it and look at just the the double speak that
we see here. All right, let's get started. The
Republican Party can never again be respected or
strong with political, quote, leaders like Mitch
McConnell at its helm. McConnell's dedication to
business as usual status quo policies, together
with his lack of political insight, wisdom,
skill and personality, has rapidly driven him
from majority leader to minority leader. And it
will only get worse. So Trump here putting
the blame of Republicans losing the Senate
on everybody but himself. This is common. Trump
does this all the time, blame other people.
The reality is that Trump's failures, including
his failure on covid, are a big part of not only
why he lost the White House, but why Republicans
lost the Senate. So Trump blaming other people
he should be looking at himself, Trump going on.
The Democrats and Chuck Schumer play McConnell
like a fiddle. They've never had it so good and
they want to keep it that way. We know our America
first agenda is a winner, not McConnell's Beltway
first agenda or Biden's America last in 2020. I
received the most votes of any sitting president
in history, almost 75 million. Now, remember,
he lost by millions of votes. The real story
is Biden got more votes than anybody ever.
Trump goes on every incumbent House Republican
one for the first time in decades, and we flipped
15 seats, almost costing Nancy Pelosi her job,
Republicans won majorities in at least 59 of the
ninety eight partizan legislative chambers. And
the Democrats failed to flip a single legislative
chamber from red to blue. And in Mitch's Senate
over the last two election cycles, I single
handedly saved at least 12 Senate seats. That's
delusions of grandeur, more than eight in the 2010
cycle alone. And then came the Georgia disaster,
where we should have won both U.S. Senate seats.
But McConnell matched the Democrat offer of
two thousand dollar stimulus checks with six
hundred dollars. How does that work? It became the
Democrats principle advertisement and a big winner
for them. It was. Trump ignores that neither
David Perdue nor Kelly Lefler, the two Georgia
incumbent Republicans who lost, were loudly
out there talking about two thousand dollars.
Understand that as well, so putting
it on McConnell from another state
when when it doesn't really bear any resemblance
to what actually took place, there is very weird.
Trump then goes on. McConnell then put himself
one of the most unpopular politicians in the
U.S. into the advertisements. Many Republicans
in Georgia voted Democrat or just didn't vote
because of their anguish at their inept governor
Brian Kemp, Secretary of State Brad Raffensperger
and the Republican Party for not doing its job on
election integrity during the 2012 presidential
race. This appears to be totally wrong, Trump is
saying. The reason Georgia incumbent Republicans
Perdue and Lefler lost is that Georgia Republican
officials didn't didn't go with everything. Trump
wanted to try to steal the election from Joe
Biden. The truth is, many Georgia Republicans
opted out because they were disgusted at
Trump trying to steal the election and they
didn't want to reward Lefler and Perdue by
voting for them, given their alignment with
Donald Trump. Trump continues. It was a complete
election disaster in Georgia and certain other
swing states. McConnell did nothing and will never
do what needs to be done in order to secure a fair
and just electoral system into the future. He
doesn't have what it takes, never did and never
will. Now, this is, of course, sour grapes.
I think McConnell's disgusting, but McConnell
has been an insanely effective operator for the
Republican Party, holding off on the Senate, the
Supreme Court seat that should have been filled by
Merrick Garland by with Barack Obama's selection,
held it open for Trump to pick somebody got
hundreds of conservative judges approved. I
think McConnell's disgusting, but to say he's been
ineffective is wrong. And Trump, this is just now
sour grapes. Trump going on. My only regret
is that McConnell begged for my strong support
and endorsement before the great people of
Kentucky in the 2020 election. And I gave it
to him. He went from one point down to 20 points
up and won. How quickly he forgets. Without my
endorsement, McConnell would have lost and lost
badly. Now his numbers are lower than ever before.
He is destroying the Republican side of the Senate
and in so doing, seriously hurting our country.
Likewise, McConnell has no credibility on
China because of his family's substantial
Chinese business holdings. He does nothing on
this tremendous economic and military threat.
Funny how Trump didn't care about that when he was
working with McConnell and had McConnell's wife,
Elaine Chao, as his secretary of transportation.
Mitch is a dour, sullen and unsmiling political
hack. And if Republican senators are going
to stay with them, they will not win again.
He will never do what needs to be done or
what is right for our country where necessary
and appropriate. I will back primary rivals
who espouse making America great again and
our policy of America first. We want brilliant,
strong, thoughtful and compassionate leadership.
Prior to the pandemic, we produced the
greatest economy, OK, blah, blah, blah.
Trump goes on with some stuff that that is just
his normal bragging. This is very interesting.
First of all, I think that it's important
to understand that at a big picture level,
Trump right now still represents the majority
of the Republican electorate, 64 percent of the
Republican electorate willing to leave the party
if Trump starts his own party. Eighty nine percent
of the Republican electorate wants Trump
to stay significantly involved in politics.
That being said, I have argued that a split in the
Republican Party is good for the left if the left
is ready to take advantage of it. The risk, of
course, is if it goes neocon versus kuhnen, right
standard Republicans and then the Trump crazies,
if they split, if it's kuhnen versus neocon,
if Kuhnen wins, if it grows and wins, it would be
really bad for the United States and the world.
That's the risk. I don't believe that that's
likely to happen. But it remains to be seen as
far as McConnell goes, you know, if Trump's going
to primary try to primary Republicans, I think
that big picture that's also good for Democrats
and for the left. I don't think McConnell really
cares about this. McConnell, six years from
now when Mitch McConnell's 84 and he's running
maybe for reelection and Trump is 80, I don't know
that this internal challenge or threat from Trump
is going to really be that big of a deal.
But that's the latest for now. And Donald
Trump appearing to launch a civil
war on his own Republican Party.
Very, very interesting. And we'll have more
coverage of this on our Instagram page.
You can follow us on Instagram at David
Pakman show. We'll be back right after this.